الانتفاضه او الثوره في ايران كما اسمها
الرئيس الفرنسي مانيوال ماكرون تحدث صدعا
في القاعده الايديولوجيه للنظام منذ قتل
الشابه مهسا اميني في السادس عشر من
سبتمبر الماضي الصف الايرانيون في طول
البلاد وعرضها منددين بالقمع المنهج
للحريات والحقوق الذي تمارسه السلطات عبر
اجهزتها من حرس ثوري وبسيج وشرطه اداب
وغيرها
صفافا حلله الباحث الفرنسي ستيفان ضد وان
يو في مقابله مع لوموند انه يمثل تاكل
ملحوظا في القاعده لجيولوجيه للنظام اذ
لاحظ دودو ظهورا انقسام قوي بين الاجيال
داخل الحرس الثوري اولا بين القاعده
والضباط الشباب وقاده الاركان وبين القاده
والضباط السابقين المرموقين الذين اصبحوا
الان منتقدين حادين للاوضاع الحاليه
[موسيقى]
احتفظ القاده السابقون بنفوذ معين من خلال
مدوناتهم والتي تكون احيانا قاسيه جدا او
في وكالاتهم الصحفيه مثل تناك التي اسسها
القائد العام السابق للحرس الثوري محسن
رضائي تشكك البعض في الكفاءه الفنيه
للموظفين الامنيين الحاليين وشرطه الاداب
والمراكز المحليه في البسيج والهيئات
المسؤوله عن الرقابه الاجتماعيه والسياسيه
على المستوى المحلي واصر البعض الاخر على
الحاجه الى الحوار وسرعان من انضم اليهم
زعماء ديني طرحوا فكره احداث تغيير سياسي
جذري في البلاد
القمع الشرس للاحتجاجات بدا في المناطق
النائيه بدءا من سيستان بلوشستان حيث بلغ
عدد القتلى فيها حوالي 3 المتظاهرين بينما
يمثل البلوش الثلاثه بالمئه فقط من سكان
ايران وكذلك في منطقه اذربيجان وفقد صحيفه
الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
لكن لا يبدو ان اصوات التغيير والقاده
تلقى اذانا صاغيه لدى المرشد الايراني
بحسب وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه انه رغم
الشرور ستتواصل او ستواصل الامه الايرانيه
المضيئه قدما وشدد على ان هدف ايران هو
ابطال الديمقراطيه الليبراليه
تقوده المناطق الكرديه بشكل خاص الانتفاض
في ايران ومنها مدينه مهاد الواقعه شمال
غرب البلاد التي تحمل رمزيه خاصه لماذا
لان مهابات شهدت عام 46 من القرن الماضي
جمهوريه مهابات الكرديه التي استمرت في
العيش عاما واحدا فقط تعاني المدينه اليوم
قمعا شديدا
وشهدت ليلى ساخنه نتيجه الهج مكثف للقوات
الامنيه والعسكريه بالاسلحه الثقيله ضد
المحتاجين المحتجون خرجوا منذ صباح امس
للمشاركه في جنازه كما الاحمد بور الذي
قتل يوم الجمعه برصاص الامن وفوق ذلك قطعت
الكهرباء والانترنت عن المدينه وتعالت
الاصوات المناديه باغاثه الاهالي بدوره
حذر الحزب الديمقراطي الكردي في بيان من
الوضع الخطير في تلك المدينه منبها الى ان
الحرس الثوري يحشد عناصره للهجوم على
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
حصيله القمع حتى الان واثقه وكاله انباء
حقوق الانسان الايرانيه هيرانا بلغت 400
واربعه قتله بينهم ثمانيه وخمسون طفلا
ومراهقا بينما اعتقل 16 الفن
1813 محتجا بينهم
524 طالبا وبحسب الوكاله شاركت 150
مدينه ومئه واربع 140 جامعه على مستوى
البلاد في الاحتجاجات المستمره وتم تشكيل
الف وثمانيه تجمعات في المدن والجامعات
حتى الان
[موسيقى]